[Music]
i've been
dreaming
every night
the same
nightmare
stranger
the fate of the multiverse
depends on us
careful stephen
this path exacts a heavy tall
[Music]
okay
marvel studios dr strange in the
multiverse of madness holding beaters
may 6th as it gets on sale now
[Music]
fate
has no mercy
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Applause]
i cannot escape my faint
[Music]
it is time to stop seeing
[Music]
it is time to stop speaking
[Music]
it is time
to listen
it is time to stop seeing
it is time to stop speaking
it is time
to listen
listen
listen
listen
[Music]
why do you want to be a samurai
[Music]
i lived in a bad part of town full of
bad dogs
everybody always picked on me
i thought if i could be a samurai
it would change everything
sounds like you need a mentor perhaps a
once great samurai who has fallen on
hard times maybe could use some help
himself
but where can i find one
get out of here who even made that it's
you don't believe everything you read
[Music]
sorry hank you have to do something
you're under arrest
you wanted to be a samurai fun isn't it
[Music]
hey this is the training montage isn't
it sometimes you need a friend
[Applause]
don't forget to land on your
[Music]
send a tweet to assemble the troops
who knew an evil army could go through
so many beams
[Laughter]
[Applause]
what the mother father cocker spaniels
going on here
the legend of hank
time to finish this
this might take a while
kingdom of bhutan
[Music]
some of our most important magic has his
origins there they say if you listen
carefully enough the past whispers to
you
the world as we know it is coming undone
things that seem unimaginable today
will seem inevitable tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]
i imagine that you're all wondering
where you find yourselves here
from this moment forward each of us has
been assigned a role to play
if we're to defeat renuka you'll have to
trust me even when every instinct tells
you not to dumbledore said i give you
something
are you kidding me right now
[Music]
what are you doing is madness
with or without you i'll burn down their
world
rescuing me are you
well done
i have to save the world are we not to
worry
you'll be perfectly safe
oh wow with the knuckles
begins
today
how will we fulfill our destinies and
transform the world
you're not swiveling properly i'm
swiveling it you're serving it
i don't believe you are
[Music]
uh
[Music]
though
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
happy dancers
[Music]
ah
[Music]
watch this critics agree the bad guys
are good
three two one
[Music]
what i just wanted a longer car chase
what's the best part get them
it's show time webs hit it
you don't want to miss this
[Applause]
the bad guys become the good guys so we
can stay in the van gang
i want you to rescue helpless guinea
pigs are you kidding me we're supposed
to save them not eat them well i'd say
they've gone to a better place
we may be bad but we're so good at it
[Music]
once upon a pair of sneakers there lived
a boy who was full of creativity you
believe that sneakers are a window to
the soul
if you put enough of yourself into a
design it's gonna hit
once i slip on that sneaker
it's my story
but possibility and opportunity can feel
as far away as a castle in the clouds
seeker royalty designed for the king
brand that's my dream we need to
dominate sneaker con we need something
big we need a new voice someone fresh
find a designer that speaks to you tells
a story we'll try it out
now we just gotta find him
you are very talented i just scribble in
my notebook i'm a stock boy i think i
hear your stepfather talking this is the
real world not some doodle or some
nonsense you're dreaming about
and clean that up too
he held tight to his dreams but would
this kingdom give him a chance film the
king's charity yeah design some safe
kicks there's not enough time for that
come on you've got sneakers to make
[Music]
you put in the workout you're ready for
the big night then
[Music]
sorry
wait a second did you design this you're
the guy that everybody's been talking
about
i really gotta get them out of here
what would become of his dream
well that would be its own kind of magic
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i was looking in your file
you're not the usual fish are you
i see that sort of behavior
as an advantage for you
it could be advantageous to everyone
including your country
want a gig
tell me more
we kidnap people
and transport them to other countries
willing to look the other way while we
interrogate them
what do you want do you know this guy
he's radicalizing young kids you got a
20 on the target
you know what's required get your hands
dirty
no restraints
target's secure
the clock is ticking
somebody is really aching for this guy
there's something they're not telling us
i'm just a foot soldier they don't tell
me anything
the more we know the more we're
accountable to
our mission is to keep the wars small
sacrifice is meaningful
just because you're american
doesn't mean your colleagues share the
same goal as you
[Applause]
we have a problem
why are we descending there's been a
major shift i'm pulling the plug
that guy knew we were coming it's
definitely a trap
for all we know this guy's controlling
the whole goddamn thing
we're next we get ready
all i know is control and orders
there's some bigger picture we're not
seeing
no matter how messy this gets
i'm not your enemy
we play a complicated game allegiances
change
we're officially in cleanup
mode time for plan b
so what's plan b
kill em all
come on
extraction ten seconds
let's do it
what do we have here yeah here i thought
we were special fellas this here's
bagman hang man whatever what the hell
kind of mission is this
[Music]
everyone here is the best there is who
the hell are they going to get to teach
us
captain pete maverick mitchell
let me be perfectly blunt you are not my
first choice you were here at the
request of admiral kazansky aka iceman
he seems to think that you have
something left to offer the navy
what that is i can't imagine
you all due respect sir i'm not a
teacher
i just want to manage expectations
good morning aviators
this is your captain speaking
and we're off
here
in three
two
one
we're going into combat on a level no
living pilot's ever seen
not even him
you think up there you're dead believe
me
my dad believed in you
i'm not gonna make the same mistake
[Music]
someone's not coming back from this
those are your pilots if anything
happens to them
you'll never forgive yourself
no turning back now come on
[Music]
[Music]
oh
boy
oh
no
oh no no no
oh
[Music]
god
oh
boy
dad i don't want to stop your flow but
can you pass the peel off oh god that's
butter you know what butter's better
you have seven days to make your payment
seven it's gonna be okay bob
happy
hopeful
kissy lips
my god please don't go down there it's
dangerous
did you mean to wave your arms all over
the place while falling into the hole
because if so you nailed it yes it all
went great
sister please
i'd like to report
a thing happened
what do we do ideas go oh
what's this thing
i'm so nervous
i know can you believe it
[Music]
that feels nice i know i know don't rub
my sesame seeds off i won't don't worry
they're a cute couple uh i give them a
year
[Music]
oh quite this is awkward
well i'd like to welcome you all to
oakwood we'll stay together no matter
what
annie just look at their little faces
i was brought here from london when i
was a little girl and it was a big
change look at all the stars you can see
let's play game hide and seek coming
ready or not
hello
[Music]
in hideout soldier spies
he's in there
[Music]
stay back are you german no i'm on your
side i'm abe
i can't talk about it but i'm on a
secret mission
if you tell anyone you're putting me and
yourselves in danger what the catch is
hiding him we can't give him up
[Music]
there's soldiers everywhere
they might find you
[Music]
got an idea but we need everyone
[Music]
it's classified information it's more
than my life's work
what are they doing probably should know
you think phyllis wasn't forever telling
me about your childhood antics
not antics action
we need to go it's now whenever
you've got to be joking you want to get
on that train don't you
go go go this is the fastest it goes
it's a tractor
now
[Music]
you can make a difference there's always
hope
friends are special
they're with us side by side
[Music]
good night good night yes yes yes good
night
[Music]
there are a lot of other villains in the
world
but i am going to be
a super villain
this world is mine for the taking make
me king as we move toward a world order
this puny little child thinks he can be
a villain i am pretty despicable
please stop calling me that time
[Music]
my minions will save me
you like picking on little guys huh i am
a master of kung-fu
i will teach you
here
kevin kevin kevin
[Music]
[Music]
why don't we make this a fair fight
[Music]
all right so i'm making like a little
documentary oh it's like a movie but
nobody has any lines and nobody even
knows what it is while they're making it
um
no
tell me about what's life like
it's pretty much common knowledge that
it takes at least 20 shells to have a
community my cousin fell asleep in a
pocket and that's why i don't like the
saying everything comes out of the wash
because sometimes it doesn't or
sometimes it does and they're just like
a completely different person
so it's actually only two of us now
myself and my grandmother nana connie we
like to watch 60 minutes because leslie
stall is fearless
[Music]
sometimes i find my mind wandering
thinking
what would my family think
do you think they could be out there
let's forget about being afraid just
take the adventure okay
let's do it
hi everybody it's marcel i'm recording
this video because i'm looking for my
family
[Music]
marcel michelle and the search for a
family reunited
marcel how long has it been since you've
seen your family i couldn't tell you but
a space in my heart gets bigger and
louder every day
dean do you know how long that's two
years two years yeah oh that's nice to
know
[Music]
there's so many places that they could
be
marcel the shell with shoes on
you are beautiful
there must be so many others like me
[Music]
he has got to go
not that i don't like arthur
not that
[Music]
i need to be on my a-game to get into
cal arts through your medium of choice
show us your happiest moment no pressure
though paige come on no edibles before
school we've talked about this
[Music]
that would be my best friend dylan
he's kind of like my platonic soulmate
you think that your crush on gabriella
campbell's is cal art worthy this
semester i'm gonna make my move oh yeah
name one time they made a move
she in slow motion again yeah music
playing in the background you were a
lost cause
it's time for you to move on there are
plenty of other queer options for you
today like who what about chantal oh no
she's tried to put a love spell on me at
least six times wait duh what about aj
why would i ever do that that's gabby's
sister hey what about amy gateway gay
she's fingered every girl on the school
so what i'm sure she's washed her hands
hey
are you coming out today i've actually
i've been out for a really long time i'm
extremely gay i was actually talking
about track tryouts
right
maybe i'll see you later so long
really you track tryouts listen up uh aj
you're gonna train paige
isn't that literally your job as coach
my job as coach is to motivate through
fear
to track why i thought you were more
interested in art since you asked none
of it feels right to me
don't be afraid to draw something a
little more vulnerable
[Music]
now i have to become an athlete
make the perfect thing for cal arts
and pick the right girls
i haven't kissed anyone i don't know how
to kiss yeah you're probably a terrible
because you need to teach me no
no means no paige come on
do me a favor and try and get a little
page here to loosen up a little bit
[Music]
is it root vegetable season because it's
turn up time
i'm learning that when it comes to art
you can't force it
it's a lot like love
i took the liberty of washing your sex
toy by the way this is very small it
could totally get lost up there
well that's an eraser so that's not
gonna go up there anything's possible
[Music]
[Music]
a
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] you you're gonna work three times
as hard
then maybe you should respect the group
you can go home
[Music]
wow
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you